um mischenko or no that was amazing
yeah yes yes do you think if those were
to show at the end of the end between
the fourth and fifth round when Raquel
Perico penance and said I went out and
her team said no that it would have been
different if it was two male fighters I
think it would have been I think it
would been as well yeah one I
I believe that had her team let her out
she would have regretted it the rest of
her life the failure and didn't happen
by her team there in between the fourth
and the fifth round
it happened in preparation getting her
ready for that because I think that that
that those words would never be uttered
out of my mouth in the middle of the
fight it would be my team begging and
pleading for them to end the fight I
don't know if there was a route for her
to win that fight if there was a path to
victory for her I don't think there was
and I think she felt that but I think
the journalist and the MMA media
attacked her coaches unfairly won
because she's a girl
I think that played a part in it
everybody's like oh my gosh this girl
fight her in between 4 and 5 she's just
a fighter
first of all right and her coaches know
her better than anybody I'm not
defending what they did or attacking
them what I'm saying is you're not on
either side of that fence and you've
never had your feet on that canvas and
felt the fury and pain of defeat and the
sweetness of success and the worst thing
ever
is regret and I have you you feel like
she would have regretted even though
absolutely agree that there was no path
to victory yeah I think Amanda Nunez was
she was surging she was destroying her
her nose was shattered she's getting
beaten down and she didn't have anything
left
true and so she's like I want out you
know Big John McCarthy and I talked
about this yesterday and he feels that
his that the corner did a big disservice
to her by letting her take a beating in
that fifth round and that every fight
take something out of you and some
fights take more out of you and there
there comes a point in time where
there's a tipping point fight and that
that could have been the tipping point
round that she might not ever be the
same again and he was saying that you
know you've got to understand that you
only have a certain amount of holes he
can punch in your ticket and if she
especially when you talk about someone
who's it but that tickets off the
tickets a fight card right that's the
ticket yes it's it's not she's not a
she's not a janitor right her yes she
only has to fight again or be beaten
down so badly in that fight that she's
never the same physically I mean we have
many times we talked about this with
Robbie Lawler or
Michael Hayes being but it might work
case with Robbie Lawler if you look at
Robbie Lara's last fight with Xavier dos
Anjos he didn't really look like the
Robbie Lawler of old now could that be
because of dos Anjos very well could
have been
dos Anjos is a beast it was our business
to tell him when he's done that's not
it's not our business
tell him he's done it's his ticket but
it's his ticket what if he wants to quit
could I says if he says he wants out
like she said she wanted out like
there's certain times in a fight where
someone says they want it like here's a
good example
do you remember Jeremy Ellen when fought
Nigel Benn yeah this is the fight that
put him into this catatonic state and
bleeding on the brain people were
criticizing him because he took a knee
people were saying like the commentators
to say what is he doing why is he doing
this well he [ __ ] knew something was
wrong and he took a knee and then
blacked out and then eventually had
bleeding on the brain like general
McClellan was a beast I mean a world
champion boxer but he knew something was
wrong
now if Raquel Pennington had said I want
out and her coach said no go back in
there and then she goes back in there
and collapses and has bleeding in the
brain and wounds up in the same state as
Gerald McClellan then people would be
going crazy yeah
I know your point because that's the
kind of fighter you are that's the kind
of fighter you were you are a die on
your sword guy that's that's what you
always did yeah and you've had some
[ __ ] amazing fights because of that
attitude and that never-quit mentality
where you were in there to win or die
trying'
god I'm so scared that regret though
I understand it you know and I don't
know if all the things that I have to
because I I hope you like mentally
checking out at the end of the UO Romero
fight you know I regret that to the day
I died that I didn't stick because I'm
looking at Dana anticipating my money
you know I'm already looking and be like
you know you're gonna pay me for this
one this is one hell of a fight right
right looking thinking about me destroy
Michael Bisbing this that's what it's
already thinking about I already left
the ring so I have that regret that like
nags at me I can't even imagine what the
regret would be like for me not to go
out all that's all like all my I don't
have post-traumatic stress but all the
things that nag at me it's the things
that I didn't do and it's a regrets but
there aren't those things what make you
better
the the realization of the mistakes that
you made those are the lessons and
that's what makes you a stronger person
you don't you don't get stronger by
doing the right thing every single time
part of getting stronger is by [ __ ]
up and having this horrible feeling that
you [ __ ] up and realizing you never
want to feel that again yep yes mum
that's how muscle and that's how a brain
works is is you you damaged it and it
comes back stronger yeah you know and I
think that's how the human condition is
to a degree but you know the hurry to
failure the rush to failure or yeah
that's how you get better but I want
that that point where I'm gonna fail to
be so unattainable and so hard to reach
where if I ever reach that point of
failure and I I mean I every time I go
to the gym and I'm training it on it and
I want you come and hang out with us one
day if you ever make it back to Austin
and we try and find the quitter in each
other every single time that we train
every time that's what we say like we
even have workouts called find the
quitter and we have we have guys
professional athletes from all sorts of
sports come in and join us and they they
will quit in the middle of in the middle
of one of our just strength and
conditioning workouts and it's because
my little group Shan Wan myself we are
looking for that failure and it's
getting so hard to find just like
shooting I'm looking for that miss
because that miss is that opportunity
that I'm gonna get better I'm looking at
that that that rep that I just can't get
or that
30-mile one more time you know because
that's gonna be the opportunity for
growth so I agree with you but it also
has to be hard to reach cuz failure
should never be easy
so you think her being able to say I
want out that she still had enough left
to keep going
I don't know I think only her in her
corner are gonna know that I would say I
would say that I agree with you except I
have so much respect for her and I think
she's one of the toughest girls in MMA
one of the toughest people and it she's
a [ __ ] animal Raquel Pennington she
really is tough I'm a big fan of hers
when someone like her says I'm out I'm
done I just think she's beaten down so
badly that she doesn't physically have
the ability to fight anymore and then
she went out and proved that in the
fifth round and took a ferocious beating
but she agrees with you she agrees with
her coaches she agrees she says now
after the fact that her coaches were
right and that she had hit this moment
of weakness if I sit on the stool and my
coach and I told my coaches I went out
you know I got Greg Jackson Winkeljohn
Nick Palma Sean o all sitting there and
they let me out I would hate them
forever
I would I would regret my decision and I
would be mad at them forever
and they're there they're there some of
my best friends now what if right after
you said that you collapsed and they
took you to the hospital and they had to
open up your skull to alleviate pressure
in your brain because you were bleeding
internally and your legs stopped working
and you're in a wheelchair like Gerald
McClellan trying to relive the pass
through distant foggy memories that
would be less than ideal sure well I
understand what you're saying it's like
the the balance of the physical
limitations of the human body and then
the limitations of the mind and the
minds willingness to find a way out